51 52 53 54 55 56 57 58 59 60 61 62 63
me par an quatre contes en campagne au
bonjour aso comment t'appelles-tu temps
d'où viens tu as je vois tu ne sais pas
parler un joli les enfants veulent y
voir donner à regarder bien ici un
oiseau il ne veut pas me dire son nom
or qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être comme
espèces d'oiseaux vous connaissez des
noms d'oiseaux
valérie le dire assez poétique ça mais
je sais pas si c'est un oiseau lyre naïs
un perroquet wi lan a les couleurs
mêlant la pala fort muriel kamari la
canary c'est toujours d'un canari là il
a un peu de jaune seulement post il veut
un pinson non je crois pas il a la
taille du pain sont là il est étrange
cet oiseau c'est un jean paul à pélican
et ils ont un gros un gros becs le
pélican jean-paul un perroquet baïla les
couleurs du perroquet oui c'est vrai
mais il a pas de doute at il eu très
très bizarre je sais pas non plus à
partir aucune race de ces oiseaux la
toison pas une autruche non plus dont
vous n'auriez pas vu un oiseau oui mais
voilà là je croyais avoir perdu ça fait
bien plaisir de le retrouver
c'est à quoi votre oiseau c'est parce
que c'est écouter
m
[Musique]
c'est un petit oiseau des îles un petit
oiseau de couleurs si tu le vois pas
aller dans la banque suisse connaîtra de
badens si tu veux boire volé dans la
grande île
si le oui tu connaîtras le bonheur
[Musique]
c'est un petit oiseau des îles qui est
entré dans mon cas il c'est faux c'est
dans la vie tranquille et marie je
m'appelle balade il s'est posé dans la
vie tranquille et marie-jo me plaire
m
[Musique]
depuis ce jour là je vis
un peu comme au paradis
et si tu veux boire l'amour rien chez
moi faire un tour d'honneur
non non non non
c'est un petit oiseau des îles qui
mangent au creux de ma main
c'est un temps
toi tu feras g10 chancerel chez le matin
c'est tintin
toi un fragile qui chantent sous la
douche heures
m
[Musique]
depuis ce jour là je dis un peu comme au
paradis
et si tu veux voir l'amour
d'ailleurs chez moi
[Musique]
non
c'est un petit oiseau des îles un petit
oiseau de couleurs si tu le vois aller
dans la grande ville suit le but
connaîtra le bonheur situe le bois volet
de la grandville suis heureux que
connaîtra le bonheur
si tu veux boire à l'aide d'algorithmes
6e et qui connaîtra de bonheur si tu
doivent aller de l'avant ville suit le
et tu connaîtras le bonheur